thank you to all the people that like I
wish I could say thank you to all people
that try to like believe in somebody
when they look like they're a train
wreck because there's all like I mean
most of your stories they're of train
wrecks in in
progress and I'm so happy and so
grateful that I got to come out of it
with an intact brain and a life worth
living and I did it by the time I was 25
not everyone gets that and I often
forget how how rare that is and I'm so
grateful I'm so grateful to God and
everyone that was involved that I got
here all right Josh yes sir Josh uh
where you from originally where did you
grow up I was born in Sydney Ohio and
then in when I turned seven we my family
moved to the Columbus area and I grew up
in Plain City for the most part
um uh when we moved here was because my
dad he he needed a place closer to his
job and he was driving like 90 minutes
to get to
work
um how would you describe your childood
uh I grew up in like a like a middle of
nowhere when I was seven and then moved
to suburbs but my family I have older
brother younger younger brother and
younger
sister
um and we as we grew up we kind of like
all kind of drifted in our own
personalities despite all being growing
up together we're all very very
different
um
and when I where we lived it was kind of
like
you where where I live now you to worry
about like getting hit by a car you to
worry about
getting uh a lot more like
there a lot of influences but out there
it's like you're in the middle of
nowhere uh we like our dog we none of
our dogs were on leashes and then as we
grew up like my both my parents when we
lived in Plain City we always took our
dog out on leash but back in Sydney our
dogs were never on leashes
um when I
was uh
five uh
my my mom like would babysit kids cuz it
my mom's a chemistry teacher um at High
School uh but back then she was not
working CU she had to take care of three
three or four kids uh my mom would
babysit this girl that came over for
uh she babysit this this girl that came
over for
um like after school before school and
well back then it was
preschool um and when we were kids uh we
kind of like our parents kind of left us
how we by ourselves a lot
uh I mean they were in the house but
they left us by ourselves
and uh I kind of remember I remember
this very vividly but I don't remember a
lot of what I was doing
um we would I liked this girl she liked
me and uh we were the same age and we
would like get we had like a bunk bed in
my family like my my parents never had a
lot of money so even when we moved to
Plain City we would sleep like three
guys in a bunk bed uh like two on top
one on bottom or vice versa um and so
back in Sydney we would me and this girl
we would like get under
the we would get under the uh bunk bed
and take our clothes off and like make
out and I look back on that a lot
thinking how did I know to know those
things how old were you five five
yeah and you talk to I mean I've talked
to a lot of psychiatrists but
uh they're like oh it's Natural
Curiosity I'm like I've never heard
anyone else I've heard other people they
want to see show me yours show me mine
which I did that once later on in life
but uh from very early age I was already
promis promiscuous with
somebody um and to be clear it was
like there wasn't a force interaction at
all we both liked each other
and
um and it frustrates me in my head to
not know why some people will tell you
especially if like if you have a
disassociative identity disorder or
something like that you don't need to
know and if you force knowing it can be
destructive but for me it's very
frustrating because like I want to know
why I knew to know to want or to want to
do or try those things um but I didn't I
wasn't really sexual after that after we
moved to at all
uh
until uh in so great I was like on the
computer in my at our local library in
PL City and somebody I I was trying to
play RuneScape the M mm o
RPG um and like I got ads and there were
porn just how a lot of kids kind of get
into porn and I grew up in a Christian
household uh Assemblies of God which is
kind of Pentecostal without the skirts
and the misogyny and
that might be a little harsh but uh AG
is a little bit more like we're
charismatic but not it's not forced and
it's
not it's more about just listening to
what God has to say to like talk to
somebody else like you're here now and
we're here together it's not about oh
there's this magical influence it's
about God speaking through me to speak
to you you anyways
um uh in my whole we grew up kind of
very conservative and watching for is
not acceptable uh my f my parents
weren't
super they weren't watching me like a
hawk a lot so I kind of got away with a
lot of things
um and because in the midd child they
kind of believe the better better of you
I guess um so that turned into something
that became a daily thing for me uh by
like fourth grade I kind of figure out
how to masturbate and
uh I could I could orgasm without
ejaculation at four at fourth grade
which is kind of crazy to think about
that that's something that can happen to
somebody obviously no one's testing that
except for I mean there actually was
somebody back in the 60s that did that
to people which is weird but
um and then uh kind of on on that note
once I started getting into High School
it really weighed on me because I had
this this conflict of wanting to do this
compulsively and growing up in a church
that they weren't very judgy they they
loved me they loved you regardless of
what you're going through because a lot
of churches youday you see them they're
kind of like a fire Brimstone and right
church was never like that there was
obviously a don't do this but it was
less about
your horrible person because you did
this in more of this leads to bad
things um and no one ever was in my head
saying you're a horrible person because
of
this I think it was more of I see what
I'm doing and I know based on what I'm
being told even though I'm not telling
them what I'm doing that it's wrong um
and I think it was July 4th of 2014 I
told a friend like we were coming back
from red R and boom which is like this
big Fourth of July thing
um I to I wrote on a notes like like a
Notes app on an iPhone because back then
all I had was an iPod and I wrote and I
said I'm going to kill myself if I can't
stop doing this because I don't want to
do this and in my head I think I thought
of it as like a motivation to push
myself to stop like oh if if I have this
gigantic Force forcing me to stop then
I'll stop because I want to
stop um stop masturbating yes stop
masturbating I'm stop watching porn and
up until then like I had I was very
involved in church I went to two mission
trips every single year I would go to a
fine arts uh convention in Anaheim and
in uh Orlando at that point so I was
very involved and um I was always an
affectionate like uh caring person to
everyone was around and I think that
part of that was
sexual but it was not sexual it was just
the mo like the drive of wanting to meet
people where they're
at
um so that was July when I told somebody
how I felt and I didn't really see it as
wrong now I see it as like that's a red
flag that's that's worrying
[Music]
um the following February it kind of
like drifted in my head and I didn't
think about it I even went past the six
months I think about it but that like
the the equation of like if I have this
Force then I'll stop um was still there
the February of the following year two
kids in my
school
um committed suicide within two weeks of
each other it was I think February and
one Monday I come to school my first
period that year was
choir and it was dead silent the whole
school every every work it's like it was
cutting into you and um both of both
kids ended up being from band I was in
band 2 I played the Claret they both
played trombone one was a freshman one
was a junior the first one
was a junior I think it was a long time
ago you kind of just remember them
together they kind of blur
but um he he committed suicide and then
two weeks later we came back to school
and it happened again
and I
think like i s for someone now looking
back at my life I saw firsthand how it
affects people I saw how this hurts
people even if it wasn't it wasn't meant
to it was meant to like escape from
their pain whatever it was people didn't
understand why both of them did it but
they both hung
themselves um and they didn't really
know each other they were not it was not
a planned thing I no one thinks that it
they weren't close they kind of just
were both in band both Patron bone so
later on that year
with knowing that like I've seen this I
at the time I worked as a janitor for my
church they a daycare and I would go in
four hours a night and clean it was very
nice to have that kind of responsibility
for myself at 16 or 17
17 and uh it was October 21st
and I think I was just in a low point
and I told a
friend Daniel I was talking with him
about it and another friend Sarah who I
was I spent more time with she had a
history of mental health I think mostly
around
anxiety
and she called me because her her dad
was on the police force Daniel had
told Sarah that I was talking about
suicide or at least talking in a very
like depressed tone and she called me
and said if you don't call me back right
now I'm going to tell my dad to call the
police and he was a policeman at the
place I was located so I instantly saw
that and thought I got to do it now
because if I don't do it now someone's
going to stop me and I'll get to go to
the hospital or I didn't really think
that far but I just I didn't want anyone
to stop me and at this church it was our
secondary building where we held Youth
and um daycare so at youth group we did
whatever we want really they we got up
on the roof all the time so I quickly
got up on the roof went to the other end
and it's about 28 ft off the ground like
it's a it's an older building they move
to a newer bigger
building um and I stood up there for
about an hour kind of and my I called my
friend Daniel and he was really worried
for me and he's just promis me you won't
do anything tonight and I said I promise
I won't do anything tonight so I waited
till 12 o'clock because I'm legalistic
about that I guess
and
um and
he he was calling me up until that point
like for 15 minutes and I just said like
I could see I started to see policemen
pulling
in I later found out that Sarah had went
and told her dad and her dad got on his
radio at home and called the local
police force to come look for me
um and I could see them with their
flashlights looking for me around the
building they didn't know I was going to
do they just know I was going to do
something
and
um I was sitting I just was sitting
there so I got up I'm like I'm sorry
Daniel but I got to go I'm really sorry
I wasn't
crying I think a lot of people when they
do it their first time it's a little bit
cold something necessary
something like I've been thinking about
this long enough why cry anymore it
hurts so much it hurts so much why
should I and cry anymore because it's
just going to keep
going
and I ended up
uh I kind
of like I went to the I walked to the
edge because it's kind of slanted I
walked to the
edge and I couldn't push myself I
couldn't do it so then I walked back and
I
ran um and so I think I went right foot
first and my I think think what happened
I I didn't black out I was awake for the
whole time uh but I think what happened
because it was dark my right foot kind
of like slanted back and um it broke a
few bones in my ankle and I dislocated
and then because think I'm think of it
as I'm going up I'm upright my right
foot caught and then it kind of like
wedged back into my back and they don't
know just things happen
um I had a wedge fracture technically a
burst wedge fracture they're kind of two
separate things but in this moment you
could if you saw the xray you could see
it
um uh the vertebral bodyo of uh your
spine is kind of like building blocks on
top of each
other so in my lumbar which is right
here I had two come together like
this and it wedged down the the front of
it top of it kind of wedged into each
into it and crushed it um I didn't
really feel any pain there um you hit
the ground yeah when I hit the ground I
didn't feel the pain in my back I felt
all my foot I had no pain in my back
which um sounds weird
but you have your nerve endings and your
disc and your and going through your
spaic cord but your spaic cord I don't
think feels
anything you kind of feel the tissue
around it you don't really feel the
nerves itself I I think um so I end up
getting rushed to
the about I think like three minutes
later cops ran over with lights like did
you just jump did you just jump and I
was
like yeah yeah and I was kind of
screaming at
God I was I just want to
die I hated I hated myself for
being for wanting something like that
and not
because
for wanting what for wanting to to
masturbate and stuff
because there were at church camps and
stuff I would often come up and tell my
youth pastor and be like I just I want
to be good I want to be what God wants
me to
be and I'm not and but like what I I
don't see a path forward of how to make
this happen be the person I want to
be I think we all feel that as like
people as teenagers like we want to be
something but we don't want to get there
or we're close enough to it that we're
just like letting the drive of other
people push us in the direction that
they want us to
go um so the EMTs had come like come up
to me they got me on the ambulance put
some nerve blocker in my ankle they
didn't know anything about the back yet
until I got there got an x-ray as soon
as I got to ride
Methodist um they reset my leg um bandag
it up and then I I think the that night
they had just built a new building there
the Riverside NeuroScience Center it's
more about like back injuries than it is
about psychological obviously and so my
uh I got like one of their brand new
like he's like 36 or something like that
which is very young for a neurosurgeon
like they they there's a joke that you
go to you go do neurosurgery and you
come out being 50 years old when you're
ready to do it by yourself because you
have med school residency fellowship and
fellowship like I think they do like 12
years something like that it's crazy um
but he was very young and he was very
good they were really happy that they
got him on their team and
uh
he he told me like he didn't want to put
me in a brace because I was so young
have you ever known a kid to keep a
brace
on no no no I'm glad he he put it in
permanent um I used to be very flexible
I used to be a put like both my legs
above my head now I can't I can't do
sit-ups um but everything else I can
pretty much do he did t11 so second your
second El last rib all the way to L4
second to last lumbar joint so just
above my hips boom boom
um
uh I
the surgery supposed to take three hours
took five I guess I drank too much milk
and my bones were too strong but not
strong enough to not break and
uh after being there for about a month a
week I and on tons of
painkillers uh I went to psych
psychiatric ward
and uh I remember the first night they
rolled me in uh it was like 1:00 in the
morning and I never told anyone these
things I had thought
before and
I spent like an hour talking with the
psychiatrist
and
he he didn't really speak much he kind
of just let me talk let me spill my guts
and the following morning uh I would
wake up at like 5:00 in the morning
while I was there because I was in a
medical bed and like it would take so
much work to get crutches and come out
of the bed that I would kind of just
wait there till I saw the sun come up
and the first night I got out like it
was so early that I could
not that no one was up I couldn't eat
food I couldn't do anything it was kind
of boring but my back hurt so much I
couldn't sleep so I started to do this
thing where I would look at the building
across the street based on the shadow of
the building I could tell what time it
was so like if the shadow was at the
third window I know oh it's time to get
it's 8 o'clock I can get up I can go out
there but if it wasn't I'd wait longer
and
longer when you most people don't know
what like in Psych word and it's almost
impossible to describe
but anything can happen I uh I've been
hospitalized 24 times between the age of
17 to
24 um that was the first time I'm kind
of do an overview because they kind of
blew blur
together
um I first time I stayed it was like two
weeks uh which was in October well more
towards November by that point cuz I was
in the hospital for two weeks or a week
like the actual medical hospital so then
um and Thanksgiving I went back because
I started throwing up with the
medication they started me off which is
zolof they just thought I was
depressed
um and then in December the girl that
I've been with
uh I did not deserve that girl all the
time let me tell you she she wrote me
letters 40 letters for each day that I
would be in the hospital potentially she
wrote a letter for me to read opening it
about each
day she was a good person she had a
heart of gold um and I didn't deserve
her at the time at
least and so
um that was a real Comfort but then in
December I wanted to I really wanted to
kill myself again but I didn't want to
hurt her so you kind of have that like
that that idea that you hear from fallen
off stars like oh I don't want to be the
grenade
that's been given to you and it explodes
because I'm too close to you because I
love you but I want to love you because
it'll hurt you so
dumb um and I broke up with her
Christmas Eve how kind of me um to get
away from her and then I then tried to
swallow like 120 cedin pills along with
120 of my mom's syn Synthroid pills
which you know did nothing um because it
does nothing uh and that was the start
so then after that I got went sent to
residency a resident a resident
Hospital residential Hospital in
Cincinnati and
uh I spent a month and a half there um
they said I had bipolar mixed but I
honestly had never had a high
manic episode which I thought was like
that's kind of as I grow up I kind I
when you're young you kind of accept it
because you want an answer psychiatrist
give you an answer you take it because
you have nothing else to explain your
thoughts
um and I kind of lived with that
diagnosis for a long time I took a bifi
maintena which a shot form um that lasts
a month for about two years uh for at
one point I took cako for two years and
then another two years I took Deo for 2
years all of them at the highest doses
when I took cakle I took 400 milligrams
at night 2 in morning in the morning and
uh when I talk to people that took the
same amount they're like oh I was like a
zombie I was dead I was like barely
cognizant
um I was in and out of the hospital a
lot I met I kind of am grateful that I
kind of went through that because I met
a variety of people that I never would
have met you grew up in a small town in
the midwest in Ohio and you're your
world is so small even when you go to a
missions trip you see you think that's
outside of America that's another place
but there are places that are like that
in
America
um especially with like uh alternative
like sexualities and
alternative
uh like transgender stuff like that you
think of it as something outside of your
head and then you meet somebody that's
like that and you begin to understand
them um I still adhere to my own beliefs
I still adhere to like Christianity
and my belief of what that
means and like the worthiness to go to
heaven but regardless of what I feel
about
you what you do you're a human being to
me and that's the most important thing
because especially in that moment like I
hated myself and that like made me kill
myself cuz I constantly had a voice in
my head telling me that I wasn't enough
that I wasn't wor
worth even being considered like when I
called friends for help it sucked
because I felt like I would call like
everyone I knew on my contact list and
no one would answer because they were
busy or they had life going
on and when you're when your mental when
your depression lasts for so
long it like weighs on other people even
your own family like they don't it's so
hard like it's hard on you but you also
know hard on them and in those moments
of where you should be focusing on
yourself you have to focus on like how
much of me needing you is going to break
our
friendship
um
when
um I was in I was in on the hospital a
lot also every time I came out of the
hospital I do IOP or PHP which is
intensive outpatient imp partial
Hospital hospitalization
programs with PHP you're in you're in
the hospital for about 8 hours you know
doing coping skills that are probably
not going to help you um learning how to
color like you didn't know how to before
um there are a lot of things there that
help some people but they never helped
me they never helped me throughout all
the years that I was in the mental
health
system I I tried so many
medications and did I did like three
rounds of
ECT I did which is Electro convulsive
therapy where they put elect show on
your head sometimes two sometimes it's
one bilateral and
unilateral um and they give you seizure
because back in the day if you had they
saw that seizure patients would
not they wouldn't they would actually
feel calmer after a seizure which didn't
make no sense and so they started doing
it to people you know because that makes
sense uh without any
anesthesia um but anyways uh I did like
three rounds of that where you go from
three times a week to once every three
months and then
um I did two rounds of ketamine
treatments which are much newer and then
I
did before I I eventually stopped going
but before I did I stopped going I was
going to get uh
VNS treat treatment which is vagal nerve
stimulation where they put a like a
pacemaker here that wraps a a a wire
around your vagal nerve to regulate your
mood they use it for a long for about 10
or 20 years they've been using it for
um they've been using it
for epilepsy when you there's no way to
like mitigate your seizures and they
realized that just how ECT could help
epilepsy pep epilepsy patients could
also help psychiatric patients
um
in April of last year was the last time
I went April of 2022 was the last time
that I went to the psychiatric award
um and I no longer take
medication I no
[Music]
longer I no longer see a
therapist um
I don't really struggle with
porn uh other than just like the
Temptation no not more not really
the I don't I've really gotten to a
point
where it's a struggle but it's not one I
act on
anymore
and I mean most recently I even I quit
vaping nicotine um this past
month um
I
uh I towards the end of February of
2022 uh I was smoking marijuana and I
was going to a uh a school at OSU for
EMT school
because
um I wanted to do EMT work because I
couldn't I never got to go to school I
kind of missed so much school I missed
half of my junior year in three course
in my in my senior year
and my
when I got out I really couldn't do much
Squad did like three classes one Cal one
for Cal one for anatomy Fizz and one for
philosophy and um at a local community
college I never got to actually go to
college really so when I went to
uh when I when I finally like got stable
enough to like always do the dream of
being
EMT uh I jumped on it I finally got a
scholarship I got the school I wanted
and I got a job to pay for it an
internship everything and
then
um
my and then so like it was supposed to
start in
December and long story short like I I
never got the email that they moved the
date the start date I I was behind I
called them uh try I was able to go late
anyways um and they accused me
of of uh threatening the professor
outside of school like at work and that
simply it just wasn't true I I was angry
with him because he made the school
difficult in the sense of like it wasn't
my fault I was there late because no one
informed me that school had been put up
a week earlier and it I lost my because
of the allegation which I was not told
um like I was put under investigation
and no one told me what for and for
about two weeks I was not going to
school I was watching online
and
um I was put on administrative leave
from work as well I got a call like on
the same day where I lost my scholarship
was expelled from the school and was
fired all on the same day and it
devastated me because it was the last
dream I had because everything
everything else I wanted to do I can
ever could do because school
was
it required so much Focus that I could
not maintain it I was in out of the
hospital so much I
couldn't I couldn't
handle I couldn't handle do something
longer than three months I was in the
hospital like every three months I think
on average probably less than that I
knew no one that went there as much as I
did um but in when I got fired and
expelled and all that uh I had smoked
weed earlier that year like the previous
year and I wasn't while I was in school
but I bought like I use my tax return to
buy like 14 carts not for uh eight carts
from a friend and
so I had like I think by that time four
or five left so I was just constantly
High went to church
High
uh was at my parents house high went a
friend's house is high and
and um cuz like I just could not handle
reality at
all
um
throughout high school and
um and After High School I was really
promiscuous I think I friends would joke
with me like
I I never I I couldn't tell you how many
people I slept with like it was more
than 40 which isn't like if you talk to
some that's not not a huge number but it
was probably more than 40 like and it
wasn't with people that I wanted to date
or even that I liked it was more about
just feeling that human connection
because and you were young yeah I mean
from 17 all the way
till I mean well actually I lost my
virginity when I was 15 with a girl that
I was in long-term relationship with but
after high school I kind of just
like was a total honestly [__] boy
um
and I look back on my actions back then
like uh just in terms of like just
trying to get in your pants but at the
same
time trying to it was really confusing
because you you want to love people but
you you're you're there to make them
feel loved but making them feel loved is
part of what you want you
don't you want to love someone but you
want to be the one that loved them and
it I'm still trying to figure out what I
was trying to do then
but it was everything from like meeting
someone behind a gas station just to
have sex to drive I I once took two hits
of a dab pen and drove two hours to
toward Cincy to meet someone to have sex
spent the night and then drove
back and it's one I had not met
before I I never done a dab pen at that
point but like where you do the dab wax
and
yeah
I I kind of was everywhere um but about
two years before
I back in 20122 I think I got I mean
2020 I got diagnosed with uh borderline
personality
disorder um warranted just caveat the
doctor I had he was was diagnosing
everyone I felt like with that every
time I went they do say that it's
overdiagnosed
um but there were like I definitely
don't have
Tantrums but I
am everywhere at least I
was
uh do do you think you have a border
borderline personality disorder
I because you know so many people that
that have BPD are
suicidal just very similar to how you
describe I think I did I
mean in January January of 2022 I just
stopped taking all my meds and then I
kind of then I smoked this on a pot and
then
I quit that and I kind of found
stability I don't think the pot and that
is connected but like I think that like
definitely when I when I was 17 I was
lb uh and I broke my back like I was 140
lbs and then at my Peak I was 245 and
now I'm back to like
215 like there was a lot
of when you're constantly pumped through
medication you start to wonder is it the
medication making me this way or is it
me which is kind of like a paranoid
thought
but I I think I
did or at least I do those aren't things
that really
like personality disorders are
developed they're not something you're
born
with I think with bipolar that's
something you could be born with but BPD
you you it's something that happens to
you through your environment
and
I I don't know how I found
stability but I thank God every day I
did you're doing better now I mean I
mean
I I met my wife Justina she's been the
biggest
supporter
um in April of 2022 I got of the
hospital and I met her at church
um and she kind of like she believed in
me she she believed that like she could
see that I was
intelligent um I was intelligent I I I I
was a math student in school but I kind
of like let everything crumble because I
couldn't go to school and I was kind of
just doing odd jobs
everywhere um but she believed that I
could actually go back to school and
that I could do something with my life
um and I think having both someone beli
me and someone to fight for made life
worth living made cuz when you when
you're in that thought process of like I
want to kill kill myself because
nothing's worth nothing's worth
doing why why should I get a job why
should I go to church why should I go
around my friends I'm not going to do
anything with my life I'm not going to
go anywhere I've already burned out all
of my ends of like paths I could go like
I can't keep up the focus to actually
make a change in my life to actually get
to a place where I could go to school
every time I tried it failed there's no
point you kind of feel that hopelessness
of
like if it's comforting and it's also
it's like
a it's like you're being swaddled but
like by chains I don't know um like
you're
you the hopelessness feels safe because
every time you hope it hurts more than
it was being hopeless
stagnantly and that's the scary part is
like is this should I really believe
should I really trust that this is going
to be the time that it's actually going
to work out because every time I did
where I felt like it's going to work out
it blew up in Flames even when like with
the school thing with with the EMT
school that one hurt the most because it
wasn't my fault I didn't say anything
wrong I didn't do anything wrong and it
blew up in my face and I didn't know how
to correct it I talked to a friend from
church that was a lawyer and he didn't
really have any advice from me sadly
um
but I think that like you know if
someone was watching this
and they're in that moment of just like
utter dread or they're going through a
time where they they're in the hospital
out of the hospital in the hospital out
of the hospital going to support group
nothing's
working I definitely think that
medication is a can help a lot of people
but I think
that therapy usually does more for you
than your medication can with most most
things not ass not including like trauma
related things but I think the one thing
that really helped me that helped me get
out of that
Abyss um was being
grateful
of so when you when you when you go home
it's home it's a normal life but you
often don't think about what you have
you don't think about how much worse
life could be and a lot of people like
when you tell them like why should I be
grateful a lot of people that have
mental health issues they'll be like why
should I be happy for what I have there
are people in Africa that have nothing
that have no food no water no home how
can I be happy about this and at the
same time how can
I how can I be sad that my life sucks
when someone has it so much worse than I
do this a comparison game of like my
life sucks but his life sucks way
more I have nothing to be complaining
about but that doesn't stop you from
feeling like [__] honestly it doesn't
stop you your life sucks someone's life
sucks more you're the one living your
life who cares how much worse someone's
life is yeah if you're talking if you're
going on and on about it to them
probably dial it back but like in in
general it's okay to feel bad about your
life you know that's phrase like it's
okay not to be
okay it's okay to think that your life
sucks without thinking about someone
else's life sucking
more why do you think you're you're
doing better now okay oh yeah I
am I'm I'm asking right um I am why do
you think that
is I think it's kind of like walking or
I mean like when a baby learns how to
walk
you there's a time where you just want
to sit down you don't want to do
anything you get so lazy and you don't
want
to you don't want to try to get up again
because every time you try get up you
just fall
but um I think I'm doing great because I
have someone to support me my wife
Justina and I have someone to I have a
reason to fight because someone has
given me a dream and every time I've
fallen down I wasn't alone they said I
know it sucks but you can keep going you
can keep going the dream still exists
even if you just fell down even if the
job that you had didn't work out you
could still keep
going and when I was alone through 17 24
it felt like I
was alone even though I was like the
biggest social butterfly
possible
I had tons of friends and it didn't
matter because when I was alone I Was
Alone um
now uh when I when I met when I married
my wife I kind of like we kind of had to
like integrate her into my church and
because we did not meet at that church
and we kind of had to blend it together
and we ended up like kind of being
secluded we didn't I I was so busy all
the time I couldn't go and see my
friends like like I usually could and I
kind of got focused in my job and I kind
of let a lot my friends go and it hurt
because now I was alone again but I was
also busy so I think being busy helps
you a lot too because sometimes when
when you're alone and bored way easier
to commit suicide or try to commit
suicide or think about committing
suicide than it is to be alone and busy
um but you always need anchor and my
wife will always be my anchor in those
moments
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in all of this most
important thing I've learned is to be
vulnerable with your journey because
it'll surprise you every time who's
going to be willing to support you
through
it beautiful all right Josh thank you so
much for sharing your story you're
welcome I'm glad you're doing better now
me too I'm really glad you seem to be
great yeah I I'm in a completely
different head space right now it's it's
such a blessing because I thought I'd
never get out